vassman and a first and foremost bar was
a brilliant musician and a virtuoso such
as the world had never seen before the
in develop is dying gezina he said with
a peep everybody is moved by these
melodies and that's quite something for
a baroque composer
geezer Satan for bin dogs written beetle
it ate a rare combination of vitality
and piety and a feeling for structure
something bark always have us both emo
odd both always gives a room to feel
that you are now in a dialogue with with
something that is linked to existential
matters
here at st. thomas's church in Leipzig
Johann Sebastian Bach was the Cantor
almost three centuries ago and it was
for this church that he composed some of
his greatest music each year Leipzig
celebrates her most famous son with a
bath festival
the opening concert is relayed to the
Market Square public concerts were held
here even in box time now it's the
central venue of the annual Bach
Festival where for 10 days Bach's music
is played from morning till night more
than 100 concerts draw music lovers from
all over the world to live safe in the
local residents celebrate their bah the
theme of this year's festival was the
Vita Christi the life of Christ retold
in oratorios masses and cantatas this
program began with the cantata of Akkad
Alf performed by the st. Thomas boys
choir
bothell sudden was closer bond is my
favorite classical composer by far I
enjoy playing and listening to it again
who again bah Tim music man aha it's
where I come from and why I became a
musician speed comos leftist I come from
Leipzig I grew up here and butt belongs
to lactic st. Thomas Church where else
was he so active lifted Johann Sebastian
Bach was 38 when he arrived in leipzig
in 1723 he was already a virtuoso
organist and harpsichordist and had been
music director at the courts of imma and
curtain but he hadn't yet won fame as a
composer in Leipzig he was responsible
for composing and performing music at
the city's four main churches no one
guessed at that time that he would
become the most important musician of
his generation and the most influential
composer in history
the sister walk one for the foundation
for most musicians today where the jazz
specialists or rock musicians in their
childhood they all wanted to know bar
and feet of spices and many of them
drawn in d mood animals including modern
composers whether they come from China
or Japan America or Australia they know
barks music and that's tremendous you
don't find that anywhere else wasn't
Finland as it was other the villages
you
I hope I can show my affection for bar
without paying him this is a jazz spot
so so it is improvisation and and my
themes but still they are so much
related also to borrow so I try to give
the audience some some examples of what
is the written themes by Bach and how
they can influence on a composer of
today the way of thinking
this is also part of the Bach Festival a
late night jazz club box music continues
to influence all genres from orchestral
music to jazz and pop the Norwegian
pianist and composer ktop instead is
inspired by the clearest expression of
box musicality his invention of
brilliant melodies that can be developed
in countless variations
you
you
more than any other composer Johann
Sebastian Bach seems to have created a
universal language that speaks to
everyone there's something mysteriously
comforting about above fugue his
Christian faith was the source of his
music and when people hear about many
scents something transcendental
bacha is on the limit Oh expression
actually what you a human person can can
do but what a sacred thing is that is of
course a mystery and that that could be
also a very personal answer on that
because we had different answers and I
think that in the musical bhai to it
loads the questions and also the answers
even if you don't understand what the
answers are
when buck arrived here in 1723 leipzig
was a flourishing center of commerce and
learning
the city spiritual heart was st.
thomas's church it's Cantor's
represented life seeks devotion to music
and they enjoyed great prestige buck
conducted the church choir for 27 years
until his death in 1750
the Kendra's duties included teaching at
st. Thomas's school next door to the
church have wound to India Shula owned
San kaha lived at the school and his
first task of the day was to wake the
boys at six in the morning school began
at seven begun nicklasson wouldn't be
held choir practice every day at eleven
I know before that he gave the boys
music lessons individually and again in
the afternoon yeah tikka masala
instrumental untouched anson namitha hot
normal swish and Roy in addition I as
time allowed he taught private pupils
composed and prepared the music for the
next Sunday I don't effing food silver
he had quite a workload on Zia paragraph
rootin Albert stuck
last year the st. Thomas boys choir
celebrated its 800th anniversary with
box music it has become world-famous
the choir comprises some 100 choristers
between the ages of 9 and 18 the
conductor is Gail Christoph pillar he's
the 16th cantora since ba few ones st in
go harass the bark festival is never
ending I akiba permeates our program we
perform about cantata once a week and
more frequently during the festivals
hope TKS it's a lot of work but it's
great music and we enjoy it cause the
music won't decyl I enjoyed the
choristers are about to rehearse the [ __ ]
Sancto spirito an amazing chorus from
the B minor mass buck intended this to
sound like a choir of angels singing
praise to the Holy Spirit
Oh
Oh
ah
either cosmopolis every great composer
wrote one mass Oh to express his
consummate skill as a musician and as a
thinker the under bark was no exception
sources of x bar buck worked on this
composition for more than 20 years today
it's regarded as the epitome of his art
16 unit round I see at bar coolio in
Bali imposed the kiri a and Gloria of a
B minor mass in 1733 and performed them
the same year amatis finale this
movement was the climax a Corphish evil
the dramatic closing the changing of
cords at the end and the repetitions a
characteristic of how he emphasizes a
conclusion I'm juice accent z
Oh
yep it Neapolitan alibis Emma um we
always perform the b-flat mass at the
end of the bar festival by it's very
appropriate because it provides a short
summary of the life of Christ and of
salvation history in the Credo from the
birth of Jesus to his ascension and
reining in glory I saw him apart beasts
who are very shaft over the centuries
theologians have proclaimed God to
humanity trying to offer explanations
and proof Bach enters into dialogue with
humanity he leads us into unimaginable
realms into realities for which words
are often too cumbersome you don't have
to be religious to be moved by box music
but many people would ascribe a
mysterious spiritual beauty to it
you
just commonplace prescribe it's hard to
describe the intellect can't grasp it
you can explain lots of things with your
mind you can describe a fugue or explain
the technical aspect but the point is
that someone who doesn't have any
musical education can still be moved by
bar he unites us all in the Diallo
Luther's Reformation had taken place 200
years earlier the German states were
still deeply divided along confessional
lines Bach was firmly rooted in
Protestantism
you young guns algemeine religion played
a significant role in barks life as in
every Lutheran's life mention I know it
was a very uniform society they were
virtually no atheists no dissidents they
were virtually no Catholics in central
Germany is carp in middle dodge London
and everyone went to church on Sunday
often twice funding amazon Toxocara sure
they all said weekday services wouldn't
escape a 400 Osteen's and church music
played a significant role in people's
lives in box it had pride of place
beastie go hollow in FIBA eine deutsche
haus central hall bath was a man for
whom the experience of God was an
existential reality his music bears
witness to that at many levels
thus Co de musica the purpose of music
in the 18th century was dokey a move era
and delectable to teach move and delight
with those elements of Baroque music one
proclaimed the word of God to the
congregation that's all there was to
church music that view was uncontested
in the 18th century and ba was
completely a man of his time the
substantive abide by the festive lib as
cantor of st. thomas's church Bach was
also responsible for the music at life's
a second most important parish st.
Nicholas's church week after week he
performed cantatas that he had composed
for the Sunday service
with his structure chamber choir in the
strut guard corn orchestra conductor
Frieda banjos presented the cantata
crist lock-in todas bundan at this
year's festival it was originally
performed by Bach himself on Easter
Sunday 1707
come on familia I come from a family
where I encountered ba as a young lad a
pastor's family he kept done sweating I
chose not to become a pastor myself but
a musician capsules nevertheless the
subject is the same i'm convinced that
Bob is the greatest musician that is
under these days however I think if you
can appreciate this masterpiece and the
text as well know that Christ is risen
it takes there is nothing greater but
that's the Solverson I believe it's
possible to make this music convincing
for somebody who doesn't believe as well
as for somebody who does yeah the sneak
gloves we offer get my telus clouds
the libretto of this cantata is based on
one of Martin Luther's hymns it's about
the resurrection the subject of Easter
Oh
I
haha
haha
long after box death his work was
acclaimed as the fifth gospel and he
himself was called a fifth evangelist
this description would have pleased him
as Jesus Christ is the subject of the
Gospels he is also at the heart of
Bach's music
but musica slim offer couldna gone for
good max music is always evangelical
proclaiming the word he worked very hard
on the text putting them together we
combine their very consciously and then
set them to music in a way that
interprets and emphasizes the meaning of
the word and the meaning behind it with
powerful rhetorical effects taught over
chante on I know English formal year
another movement from the easter cantata
crystal akin todas bundan proclaiming
Christ's triumph over death
Oh
Oh
parallel to the musical presentation of
the life of Christ that was the main
focus of this year's Bach Festival
visual scan Despres chamber choir sang a
program of works by composers who
influenced bond among them his immediate
predecessor as Cantor at st. thomas's
church in Leipzig Johann kuna the motet
twist assess an Amamiya my soul grieves
has been ascribed to Kuna back zip
statistic also only was admired this
work immensely MIT ID Matty performed it
with a new text and a new instrumental
accompaniment of food so it's certainly
a piece that belongs to barks world of
church music in the MCAS they are
partying kesha musica hurt
it is
e
you
yes
the Bach Festival in Leipzig is one of
the most important it sets standards for
the interpretation of his music in the
city most closely associated with the
composer this buffest is finished the
Bach Festival has virtually become my
musical home I've lived in life see for
a long time and I was a chorister at st.
Thomas's and I've always taken part in
the bak festivals to mom as a singer bit
or conductor weekend
yeah estrin acoustic bass is the
greatest composer companies I think the
genius of a composer is something you
can't express in words it's something
deep inside which can't be described the
playful way he wrote fugues without any
artificiality beautifully constructed
and yet very emotional perhaps it's that
but ultimately it's the fact that you
can enjoy hearing the music again and
again this is the side introduces
justice most this one's mov on the world
not much is known about box private life
contemporaries described him as a
receptive man who knew how to enjoy
himself but his attitude to composing
was that of a medieval craftsman he
believed that everyone has his place in
the world where we should humbly work to
God's greater glory
you